der boden die war
die ecke
[Musik]
der teppich der bbu
denn
der teppich liegt auf dem boden
das fenster
das regal steht neben dem fenster
im regal stehen bücher
das so versteht
dem fenster
das sofa steht hinter den teppich
das bild hängt an der wand
das bild hängt über dem sofa
der fernseher steht gegenüber dem sofa
der teppich liegt zwischen
sofa und dem fernseher
in der ecke steht eine lampe
vor dem fenster steht eine pflanze
vor dem regal steht der esstisch
am esstisch sitzen personen
zwischen dem sofa und der lamm
ein tischchen
eine lampe hängt über dem esstisch
eine katze sitzt auf dem teppich
ein hund ist neben
fernseher
ein keyboard
vor der lampe
vor dem keyboard steht ein stuhl
hinter dem keyboard steht ein
lautsprecher
zwischen dem sofa und döpfner
liegen bücher
auf dem so
liegt ein laptop